all righty we've got some clouds out
there this morning color in the sky not
much in the way of wind temperatures
still falling down to freezing or below
seven hills at 28 degrees 31 at
mountains edge freezing and now up at
aliante and very close in all other
neighborhoods from henderson to nellis
to the lakes
summerlin you're there 27 at red rock
and 17 up at kyle canyon look for more
gusty winds through the mountains today
more so than what we'll see in the
valley 29 in mesquite 27 in indian
springs 30 in 28 in sandy valley and 35
in laughlin teens in ely and tonepaw
there's been more snow up around reno as
well as northern california and around
lake tahoe that snow is moving through
north central nevada right now clouds
and sunshine for us today highs in the
cool low 50s yesterday 49 was the high
we're going to have cold nights and
freezing temperatures all the way
through the weekend chance of showers
comes back on tuesday
into wednesday maybe tuesday night as we
start winter next week so maybe we'll
get some more mountain snow as well
here's that system that's diving into
the west again and the one that left us
on tuesday with all that nice snow in
the mountains and rain in the valley has
been speeding through the rockies the
plains and causing another outbreak of
tornadoes and damaging winds but man it
is raced through the great lakes snow on
the backside very warm air out ahead of
it dallas fort worth has been in the 80s
this morning 80s at this early hour all
right so speaking of snow good snow
again right through the sierra nevada
range and snow across northern nevada
here it is around reno not winding down
yet it's getting a little sketchy but
for us here in southern nevada
17 inches of snow up at lee canyon yeah
they corrected their amount yesterday
and this is an absolutely beautiful live
webcam view from their website
leecanyon.com and you can see all that
fresh snow on the ground oh it looks
like somebody's been making tracks up
the hill that looks awesome they're
going to open tomorrow at least one
chair the quad chair for rabbit peak
that's the bunny hill so skiers and
snowboarders at least you get a mini run
all right let's just get started i know
y'all been waiting for it to open
everybody has so it's going to be
beautiful 36 degrees up on the mountain
today northwest winds at least 25 miles
an hour might be stronger at times so it
is going to be cold in the mountains
today 51 for the valley winds not really
an issue today but breezy winds return
tomorrow and those could be up to 20
miles an hour or so so that's going to
make it feel extra chilly and then we
stay kind of cool through the weekend
highs in the low 50s mornings near
freezing and next week winter begins on
tuesday morning maybe some sprinkles on
tuesday and some showers on wednesday